we're breaking into programming to go
live to moscow now where the u.n
secretary general and the russian
foreign minister are speaking you can
see sergey lavrov there after the pair
met this morning let's listen it's
crucial context
um
uh it was all due to the
um uh american uh
uh partners and um um europeans to um
create a new world
um uh the new geopolitical world and as
to our um geopolitical space everything
was
uh
done in order to hold hold up the
russian federation
and ukraine was used as the uh
that's the
springboard
for
the um
for holding on russia and
russian uh ukrainian uh authorities were
encouraged to ban a russian language
russian culture everything russian in
fact and uh in parallel um they were
creating laws
creating steps which are
putting forward the nazi theory nazi
practice
in ukraine
and of course the secretary general uh
knows all about it um all those
decisions which were uh made uh by
president putin about the uh reasons the
aims
of our military operation were together
with uh the
uh militia of the donna's kindergarten
people's republic on the territory of
ukraine those aims
are
directed to the protection of the
peaceful of the civilian population and
they are interested
um in cooperation
with uh eun
colleagues and uh
international red cross uh colleagues uh
as to the the
uh alleviating the suffering of the
civilian population the u.n after when
we had contacts
with the
uh uh ministry of defense and the
general secretary um
general secretary
we decided
and we agreed uh and formed the working
group
which is based in moscow here
um
working uh within our
ministry of defense um working with the
un
that
and they're discussing the things which
uh
helped
the distribution of the authentic aid
and
we
managed to uh set up five um
convoys to different parts of ukraine um
on top of the
humanitarian aid which is on a daily
basis uh distributed among the ukrainian
citizens and also in donetsk and luhansk
on behalf of the russian um
ministry of defense and
uh
and some other uh russian um
organizations
and today we um discussed the
opportunity and the possible actions
possible steps to strengthen our
cooperation in this direction and i
think that uh
we will
we will be able to um
to
create the necessary steps
uh which we could uh take uh under
present circumstances
and of course we were talking about the
future of the united nations as a whole
about the tries of our western
colleagues
to
try to
take the discussions on all the of all
the issues outside the offices of the
united nations and creating different
partnerships and different appeals
which they're being presented as the uh
the selected club the club for the
selected and um
for instance france and germany putting
forward the the so-called
alliance of the multilateralists
what is it if it's not it's a
competition with the un or the uh us um
um idea of
the so-called uh summit of democracy and
they were sending their invitations
without consulting anyone
interlocutors today and and this is
actually a very dangerous uh signal to
the to un
the tries that attempt to cross out the
basics of the
um
charter
that this organization was set up on the
basis of the sovereign equality of this
of the countries and it
it's clearly
marked in the u.n charter and we have to
um make sure that
nobody in new york or in um
in other capitals won't forget about
this
um and i want to finish this um to
express my uh gratitude to the u.n uh
secretary general who um put forward the
initiative to create this um a meeting
to set up this meeting and we uh
play uh a lot of uh
we're very
very we're appreciating very much the
position of the united nations uh
generally secretary
uh
with all the um uh problems in world
affairs this type of the ultan
discussion is very useful that uh in the
end we will go back to the egg so to
speak that will go back to the u.n
charter
and on the basis of this charter will
build up any
any schemes and forms of the development
of the multilateralism uh which is one
of the key terms
and i'm very grateful that the secretary
general uh took this in this um
[Music]
in this context thank you ladies and
gentlemen of the press
as secretary general united nations i
came to moscow as a messenger of peace
my objective
and my agenda
is strictly linked to save lives and to
reduce suffering
i had a very frank discussion with the
foreign minister sergey lavrov
and it is clear that there are two
different positions on what is happening
in ukraine
according to the russian federation what
is taking place is a special military
operation
with the objectives that were announced
according to the u.n in line with
resolutions passed by the general
assembly
russia's invasion of ukraine is a
violation of its territorial integrity
and against the charter of united
nations
but it is my deep conviction
that the sooner
we end this war the better
for the people of ukraine
for the people of the russian federation
and those far beyond
the united nations has repeatedly called
for ceasefires to protect civilians and
to facilitate the political dialogue to
reach a solution
so far that has not been possible
today across the zombas a violent battle
is underway with tremendous deaths and
destruction
many civilians are being killed and
hundreds of thousands of people are in
life-threatening conditions trapped by
the conflict
i'm concerned about the repeated reports
the violations of international
humanitarian and human rights law and
possible war crimes
and they require
independent
investigation
for effective accountability
and we urgently need
humanitarian corridors that are truly
safe and effective
and uh that are respected by all
to evacuate civilians
and deliver much needed assistance
to that end
i have proposed the establishment of a
humanitarian contact group
bringing together the russian federation
ukraine and the united nations
to look for opportunities for the
opening of safe corridors with local
cessation of hostilities
and to guarantee that they are actually
effective
simultaneously
we recognize that we face a crisis in a
crisis in mario paul
thousands of civilians are in dire need
of life-saving humanitarian assistance
and many of evacuation
the united nations is ready to fully
mobilize its human and logistical
resources to help save lives in mario
paul
my proposal is for a coordinated work of
the united nations the international
committee of the red cross and ukraine
and russian federation forces
to enable the safe evacuation of those
civilians who want to live
both inside the azov style plan and in
the city
in any direction they choose
and to deliver humanitarian aid required
and this is not just about
what is happening in ukraine as we are
seeing shock waves around the world
the dramatic acceleration of the
increase of the prices for food and
energy
that was already taking place in the
last year
are causing enormous suffering to
hundreds of millions of the most
vulnerable people worldwide
and this caps on top of the shock of the
continuous covered 19 pandemic
and the uneven access to resources for
recovery
that particularly penalize developing
countries around the world
and so the sooner
peace is established
the better
for the sake of ukraine
russia and for the world
and it's very important even in these
moments
of
difficulty
to keep alive the values of
multilateralism
we
need a world that is multipolar
with multilateral institutions
and those multilateral institutions must
abide
by the end charter and by international
law
and abiding by the event charter and by
international law recognizing full
equality among states
they hopefully will be an instrument
that will allow us once again to come
together as humankind and address the
dramatic challenges we face
from climate change to epidemics and to
many others
and in which
the only war
we should have
would be a war
of those that put the planet at risk
today
good afternoon i am geeta mohan from
india today mike uh i have a question
each from both the leadership beginning
with the united nations secretary
general sir mr gutierrez sir
there are allegations and
counter-allegations regarding
genocide war crimes human shields as
also
reports of chemical weapons and
biological weapons being used you spoke
about contact group and humanitarian
corridors you also spoke about
investigations will the united nations
look at independent investigations
creating a team and investigating team
to look into the facts on the ground
and
and my question to the foreign minister
sir
both sides
whether it's the united nations or the
international community are looking at
negotiated settlement and ceasefire
should russia look at a negotiated
settlement is there a country or an
organization that could act as a
mediator who would russia consider as a
mediating agency
thank you
well the u.n secretariat has not the
power to do investigations of that kind
we have
the international criminal court
we have
the different mechanisms that exist in
the human rights system namely
commissions of inquiry
it is not my intention to promote an
investigation myself i have not the
authority for it but i think it's very
important to have independent
investigations in order to have full
credibility and full accountability
my part of question um in the beginning
i just would like to say
that the positions that the world
community um uh takes now and how uh the
u.n should um bear that in mind
um uh with uh the u.n um the charter
with the sovereign um uh equality of the
states as i mentioned uh mr secretary
general uh mentioned the general
assembly resolution which um uh
condemned russia
and um uh called what is uh happening in
russia as an invasion the
the breach of sovereignty and uh
integrity and um i have to say there
wasn't consensus on this resolution that
many
countries were complaining to us that
they were made
vote a certain way and the ambassadors
were basically capturing uh captions in
the corridors of one and the you uh
american friends uh clearly know how to
threaten people because
your children are in the u.s your
children are in the u.s universities
nevertheless the this resolution was not
adopted um
unanimously um a couple of dozens of
countries refused to support it clearly
all the um
u.n um resolutions should be uh as a as
a mandate
but the security council
resolutions also should be sacrosanct uh
especially the resolutions which were
adapted by the all
the consensus of all the 15 uh members
when they all vote for a certain
decision and
back in february 2015 with the consensus
we adopted a document which was called
the minsk list of measures which gives
us the uh
way to the uh
direct dialogue between kiev and donetsk
and luhansk in order to settle all the
problems within the boundaries of the uh
territorial integrity of ukraine
we had to
just
uh to fulfill
this document which president poroshenko
then uh president
signed and to give a special status to
donetsk and luhansk declared republics
and uh declare amnesty
make sure that the
ukrainian constitution is
corrected in a certain way
but
yet at the same time keeping the
territorial integrity of ukraine and um
they had to um organize
the elections in donetsk and hence area
i don't remember the secretariat of the
united nations reacted a certain way to
this direct
sabotage of this this absolutely um
brutal sabotage of states by kiev um of
this um
ukraine uh
the conversation is impossible
to um
delay and delay
we are at the this uh period of the
development of international relations
uh where there's a moment of truth uh
comes in uh we i've uh
agreed that someone
uh and the group of his uh satellites
decides how the human kind will live
or the human kind will live on the basis
of the u.n charter this is as simple as
that nobody wants um wars god forbid
but put forward some arguments and
demand answers from someone who break
who breaches the uh
uh uncharted and i have to assure you
that more and more countries especially
countries with its own civilization um
heritage uh
language and culture wants to adopt this
position
because this conversation should happen
at some point and i really hope that
that you are un with its uh roots in the
u.n charter
the greatest document of all times
uh will play this catalytic role
in in the development of this honest
dialogue
with our ultimatums without threats
and without uh
attempts to
resolve problems by force
including um financial force and
economic economic force which uh
western colleagues possess um uh greedy
uh
making that uh
they it's it's actually unacceptable uh
as to the um decisions um we are totally
for the negotiations uh you know that
straight after the um
when in the beginning of march president
olenska suggested the negotiation we
agreed but the behavior of the ukrainian
delegations uh the behavior of the
president
himself
refusing to uh to confirm what a week
ago they uh
they they received our uh proposals it's
really sad
um uh apparently they they're not
interested in negotiations they think
that uh as they were promised um those
who
appeal
not to give russia a chance to win
uh those who uh uh
uh wants to
win over russia and destroy russia and
they'll be carrying on with this um uh
line and they'll be sending tons of uh
weaponry to ukraine and clearly if if he
goes on the negotiations will not have
any result but uh reiterate that we
we are all for the negotiations and all
for the cs5 that's what we work on a
daily basis uh declaring the
humanitarian corridors which are ignored
uh in particular uh
in uh in those uh uh rebels from the as
of battalion who wears swastikas and
symbols of nazi battalions uh ss uh um
and who uh president zielinski uh
answering the um uh
question from the cnn um uh uh
journalist he says oh we got a lot of
battalions well they are what they are
and this phrase they are what they are
they actually took out of that interview
uh because they they were ashamed to
you know to show to a
western democratic uh um society all
those thoughts of a certain person
that's why we're ready for negotiations
if someone has uh interesting ideas
we're we're prepared to listen to them
um as to the mediation um um for the
time being
uh ukrainian negotiators they were not
talking about uh mediators we were
talking um face-to-face uh once three
times in belarus
one uh one time women in turkey those uh
platforms for negotiations we are
grateful to the belarusians and uh turks
for the
opportunity but
talking about uh mediators uh i think
it's too early we want to get the uh
reply to our latest
uh uh uh
latest uh document that we passed on to
the ukrainian side and the ukrainian
negotiators
never reported to their president at
least one week later he he had no idea
about this document thank you
i'd like to say that the secretariat
entirely respects and abides by all
resolution of the general assembly and
of the security council
and today if i regret something is that
the un was not allowed to be part
of the
normandy format to follow the minsk
agreement
and to be able to form a very clear cut
opinion about the failure of the minsk
agreement
on the other hand
i'd like to say that
i
understand that the russian federation
has
many grievances but the when charter
foresees a large number of mechanisms in
which grievances can be addressed
and namely
with the recourse to the international
court of justice or other other
mechanisms if all the other ones
foreseen in the charter fail
but there is one thing
that is
true and obvious and that no arguments
can change
we have not ukrainian troops in the
territory of the russian federation
but we have russian troops in the
territory of the ukrainian federation
um i have a question to both speakers uh
mr lavrov um
we expect that there will be a void uh
on the um lichtenstein's suggestion on
the veto in the general alembi assembly
when um
one of the five members of the uh
um
security council uh uses
veto so how does moscow take this uh
proposal and uh
um uh
what about the suggestion when the vita
will be cancelled after a certain um
vote uh at the
general assembly and a question to uh mr
gutierrez uh
well you as a senator secretary general
do we need a veto in the u.n
as to
the resolutions that he's
put forward in for the general assembly
uh and this is totally um um
um uh
it won't
um uh influence any uh negotiations on
the reform on the uh united nations uh
security council reform uh uh i have to
assure you uh the veto will never go
away anywhere
and this is one of the stalwarts of the
united nations without this veto the
organization will will basically get the
demolished um because uh big countries
are the permanent members of the
security council
uh of course
they are
um
using the principle of the unanimous
unanimity
which uh
uh allows to um avoid the clashes
between them
um other thing the
world has become different
that americans want to
uh and they they publicly appeal they
want uh
the unipolar world for forever and ever
but the objective process is going the
different way uh the world is uh
multipolar
and uh we were talking that um the uh
security council should get rid of uh
the named uh fault that uh
because for instance uh six uh places
there there are western countries and
their lives and the developing countries
are not uh represented and we
were always saying that we wanted to see
an asia
africa latin america representatives uh
on the permanent basis of the security
council and we were mentioning um our
partners from india and brazil
um and uh of course there should be a um
an african candidate so
um
the resolutions that you mentioned which
comprises the discussion on the
situations um after the use the using of
the uh veto at the on the
security council it doesn't have
anything to do with uh reforms it
doesn't aim to the democratization of
the
decision making um and we're ready um to
uh join the consensus if it will be
formed
and it's very important to work with
consensus here because many resolutions
which are adopted even by the minority
uh
become uh overwhelming and the majority
of resolutions which is very uh useful
for the western countries but i will go
uh even further the security council
could be
um denied not to to adopt resolutions uh
not through vetoes
but through the abstention during the uh
voting
of six or seven countries
this is um also the case when the
security council is basically broken and
the general assembly shouldn't be um
indifferent to this situation
that's why
yes i think
this is a healthy process
if a country uses its veto
that it means this country uh has a way
to explain um its position
when it comes to russian federation
we will uh we will be um explaining all
our positions which we take in the
security council if i
am able to interpret those that so many
years ago
created the charter
i believe the reason of the veto was to
avoid the situation in which
a confrontation among
the
members
of uh
the the group of permanent members might
lead to another global war
and so the veto was a kind of a
an element introduced to avoid this kind
of danger
it is also true that as time went by
the veto has probably been used too many
times as
in many circumstances it's used without
vital interests of a country
taking
existing
and so
i i'm very much in favor of a moderate
use of the veto having no illusions
about the possibility of changing it i
don't think that it will be possible to
have a majority the two such majority in
general assembly with the five
members agreeing on changing that
but i also believe it's important to
enlarge the security council and to have
a more equitative representation
particularly the country like africa
and africa is a double victim of
colonialism first of all because it
suffered colonialism itself and second
because many of the europe the countries
only gain the independence when the
international institutions have already
been created and so africa is
underrepresented in decision-making
processes in most of the multilateral
institutions and so i do believe that a
stronger representation of developing
countries
in many areas from the bretton woods
institutions to the security council
would be an important reform
tell us
how
russia replied to the ukrainians uh to
the
to ukraine's suggestion to conduct
negotiations in mario paul
and the second question what steps
russia would take
when it comes to the
um increasing um supplies of weaponry
from the us to ukraine yes i heard about
this theatrical uh suggestion that the
ukrainian negotiators put forward uh the
team that
was
dealing with uh uh negotiators in
belarus in turkey and then um um
to uh hold the next meeting just uh by
the uh as of
still as of style uh planned in mario
yeah it's
very theatrical ukrainian ones wants to
put certain you know the stage
performance as always and they wanted
clearly this kind of really uh serious
scene to create
um uh where everyone will be crying but
as to i wish that they would um give
their quick reply to our suggestions our
proposals which we sent them over ten
days ago like you i've mentioned uh
earlier as to
the american weaponry supplies from
america to kiev not only americans
supply their weapons to kiev
they uh they prefer to make europe for
uh sending weapons to ukraine
although they they uh take those steps
too uh we were saying not many times
when the
foreign uh weapons
uh are on the ukrainian uh territory
this this would be a legitimate target
um for our special uh
operation are troops uh on the ukrainian
territory that uh protecting the rights
of the people who were bombed for eight
years
and despite the fact uh whether this
country uh took part in the normandy
format they were silent it's um france
as a co-author of the men's um
negotiations and treaties all those
years of uh horrible prosecution which
all the russian speaking
population not only in the donbass of
those two self-proclaimed republics but
ukraine as a whole have a look
it's all um in the statistics uh the
language
laws were adopted in ukraine uh on
russian languages on russian mass media
russian language not only russian uh
language uh tv channels were banned or
on the uh there were
ukrainian channels banned if they were
owned by the parliamentary opposition
and some other things
um then they decided to ban
russian language in everyday life
and i want to emphasize that nazi
ideology in practice was basically
suggested
and everyone was hiding the
hats
and the weapons that
were they were sending to ukraine back
then
it was a clear a threat to russian uh
federation
the military bases which uh in
particular the british were building on
them as of seacoast they they were
threats to russia too direct threat
unfortunately we didn't hear any
sympathetic voices uh from the different
uh parts of the world when um
the last gasp attempt we
suggested
to americans and nato members
to um set up a treaty
on the security in europe without the
enlargement of the
nato bloc
and now we um are taking uh taking up
the liquidation of those threats
elimination of those threats and uh um
all the um
what you see on the ground is
agency a question to both speakers
um
russia accredited first
diplomat from the
taliban
government does it mean that we're
moving towards recognizing the
government of the taliban in kabul and
the second question
is russia ready to work with
the afghan
political forces
in order to include include them to the
new uh inclusive
uh
afghan government as president of iran
recently suggested and the question to
mr gutierrez can you comment the illegal
extrapolation of the russian diplomatic
property in the usa and
washington's
behavior when
many russian diplomats
are being denied uh visa uh when they
want to take part in the un um events uh
uh
what steps uh un could uh undertake um
uh to uh make us behave